all right guys this is the video you've
been waiting weeks for
the comparison between our eight core
2025k
imac for 2300 and the 10 core
3300 model and as you saw in the title
we are recommending that most people do
not upgrade
to the 10 core i9 cpu for an extra 400
there are a small amount of people who
should upgrade
and i'll mention that in just a few
minutes as we get deeper into our suite
of performance
tests like video editing and final cut
pro 10
programming with xcode music production
with logic pro 10
photo editing with photoshop and
lightroom classic graphics rendering
with blender
gaming performance and more before we
get started i want to show you guys the
full specs of each machine
and one of the major differences is that
the 8 core gets the base
5500 xt graphics card and the 10 core
gets the 5700 xt
with double the vram we also paid 100
for the optional 10 gigabit ethernet
port on the high-end model
so if you don't need that port the price
goes down to 34.50
and by the way those total prices you're
seeing include the ram
that we bought from amazon and upgraded
ourselves for a significant discount
instead of paying apple's incredibly
high ram prices
so we got 32 gigs for the 8 core imac
for 120
and 64 gigs for the 10 core for just 240
off amazon and we'll have links to the
ram that we chose down in the
description below
so you can do the same and if this video
ends up helping you out consider buying
our apple product merch
like our mask or a t-shirt down below to
help support this channel
now let's get into the performance
testing starting with the geekbench 5
benchmark
and in the single core test there was
barely any difference at all
but in the multi-core test the 10 core
i9 model was around nine percent more
powerful
in terms of raw performance now in the
cinematic r20 cpu stress test
which actually factors in the cooling
systems the 10 core model was around 12
percent more powerful which is honestly
less of a difference than i was
expecting
since you're paying 400 for that cpu
upgrade
but the most interesting thing is that
during that test
the 8 core imac was actually able to get
a higher spike
in wattage and then once the temp
stabilized after multiple runs of
cinematic r20
the 10 core was running at a lower clock
speed of 4 gigahertz
because it has to keep those extra cores
cool and this is going to be very
important for some of the real world
tests that we're about to run in just
a minute but first let's go through the
graphics and the gaming tests
in geekbench 5's metal graphics test the
5700 xd
graphics in the higher end model was
about 38
more powerful than the 5500 xt
which is definitely a more impressive
difference than we saw with the 10 core
cpu
and then we ran unigine's heaven gaming
benchmark on the xtreme preset
to test the difference in real world
gaming performance
and to our surprise the higher end model
got around 50 percent more
fps which is an incredible difference
for gamers
and definitely worth the upgrade price
of 500
now as a cherry on top the 5700 xt gets
double the vram 16 gigs instead of only
8 gigs
on the 5500 xt and not only that
but the bandwidth speed is higher as
well 384 gigabytes per second
instead of 224 on the base graphics
which is going to help a lot for some of
the real world graphics tests that i'm
about to show you guys in a minute but
before we get into those video editing
tests with final cut pro 10
i want to cover some other things like
photo editing logic pro 10
and xcode programming we ran the puget
bench photoshop benchmark and we were
surprised to see
that the high end model only scored
around 5
higher even with the 10 core cpu and the
extra ram
so this shows that graphics designers
should be fine with
the lower end model now i tried to run
puget bench for after effects
multiple times but no matter what i did
it wouldn't finish the test i don't know
why
but with that let's get into the
lightroom classic testing
exporting 500 raw 42 megapixel images
and the higher end imac finished exactly
two minutes quicker which isn't much but
it's definitely something now here's the
kicker
in a previous video we actually tested
the differences in how much ram you
should buy
and while using the lower end eight core
imac
we ran the same test with 64 gigs of ram
and it finished in just 22 minutes and
10 seconds
so this not only shows how important ram
is for photo editing in lightroom
but it shows that the a core is actually
faster than the 10 core
if both of them are using 64 gigs of ram
and that's because the 8 core runs at
higher clock speeds
like we saw in the cinebench r20 test
now we also tested building one-to-one
previews
and here the 10 core imac was just four
seconds faster
than the a-core assuming both systems
have
64 gigs of ram now moving on to the max
tech xcode benchmark
which you can download using the link
below in the description
the 10 core imac finished the build only
12 seconds faster
than the a core we personally think this
is due to the fact that on the 10 core
apple is limiting the maximum wattage
and the clock speeds
to help keep the temps down while the a
core feels like it's unlocked
and free to get high spikes in wattage
which has been very
impressive so far and now moving on to
the logic pro 10 benchmark
which tests how many tracks the system
can handle before overloading
the 8 core was able to handle 123 tracks
and the 10 core was able to handle a
slightly higher
131 tracks which is once again
pretty underwhelming and honestly most
logic pro 10 users aren't
maxing out their systems with as many
tracks as possible
so the 8 core should really be fine for
most people
and by the way 64 gigs of ram with the a
core
helped it handle 125 tracks instead of
123.
now before we get started with video
editing we have just one more test to
run
and that's 3d rendering with blenders
bmw and classroom tests
which are actually using the graphics to
render instead of the cpu
in this test the higher end model
finished almost 40 percent faster than
the base model which is a pretty huge
difference
and that performance gain is due to the
5700 xt's
extra raw performance and core count now
let's finally get into video editing
with final cut
and prepare yourself because these
results are insane
in the bruce x 5k benchmark the higher
end model finished the test just
one second faster than the lower end
imac then moving on to our one minute
hvc
stabilization test the difference was
even smaller
with the high-end model finishing just
half a second faster
now the reason for that is because both
systems are using the same
exact quick sync encoders and the same
exact t2 chip
to encode the hevc footage in this test
so the extra raw performance doesn't
really help we then exported a 5 minute
4k
h.264 clip and once again the higher end
model only finished one second faster
because the hardware accelerators are
taking care of the encoding
so it's not limited at all by graphics
power
so because we didn't see a difference in
that test we exported one of our very
own maxtec videos
which is 12 minutes long and comes
packed with a bunch of effects and
charts that we use on a daily basis
and here the high-end model did finish
23 seconds faster
and we think it's because of the much
faster 384 gigabyte per second vram
bandwidth
that is able to more quickly render the
effects now moving on to our five-minute
hevc
export test the high-end model finished
just 12 seconds faster
which is honestly not much of a
difference for paying an extra 500
and of course that's because they both
have the same t2 chip
which takes care of hevc encoding now
what those tests show us is that if
you're doing basic 4k
editing there's really no difference
between the two
but as you start adding more and more
effects like we did in our 12 minute
long max tech video
the higher end 5700 xt model will start
to perform
a bit faster so keep that in mind if
you're going to be adding a lot of
effects
now getting into canon's new eos r5
footage
max did a dedicated video on his channel
for editing r5
and sony a7s3 footage so definitely
check that out after this video is over
but i do have a couple of tests to show
you guys right now in terms of
transcoding a 30 minute 4k
10 bit clip they basically finished in
the same amount of time
with neither of the machines using all
of their cpu power
so for this test the 10 core is
basically pointless
now instead of transcoding we exported a
5 minute version of this footage
and you guys are about to have your
minds blown the 10 core imac
was slower than the 8 core imac by about
8 seconds
and the only reason we could think of is
that the 8 core is running at higher
clock speeds
so if you want to see more info on that
definitely check out max's dedicated
video
now moving on to canon c200 raw footage
final cut pro just got updated to
support metal-based rendering
for this type of footage but it's
currently broken
because canon still hasn't updated their
plugin
so we ended up using the old version of
final cut to run our 5 minute export
test
and here the high-end imac was almost
two minutes
faster but the important thing to note
is that the eight core cpu is still not
the limitation
the extra gains for the higher end imac
are from the better graphics card and as
far as timeline smoothness
the high-end imac was able to play it
back at a perfect
60 frames per second compared to around
54
fps on the low end imac so the graphics
is a great investment here
moving on to redraw footage now using
the new final cut pro version
in red's newly released plug-in we ran
our five-minute 4.5 k export
and the high-end imac was over 25 faster
in this test but not because of the 10
core cpu
mostly because of the faster graphics
yet again
and now exporting our 5-minute ak clip
the high-end imac was
way faster almost 50 faster than
the other imac which is very impressive
and you might be thinking
there you go that's the 10 core cpu
finally shining
but you're wrong max tested before and
after the new final cut pro update
and the high-end imac used to export 4.5
k red raw
with 91 percent of the cpu being used
but now it went down to only 12 percent
of the cpu being used
and for the a core export it went from
100
cpu usage down to 12 cpu usage
with the graphics actually being
basically maxed out
at 98 usage so this basically shows that
in the past
red raw footage would completely max out
your cpu
and make the 10 core way worth it
but now it's mostly graphics based so
the 5700 xt
is very worth it for doing any type of
raw footage editing and as for the 8k
playback test the high-end imac played
it back at 19 fps out of 24
compared to only 12 fps on the lower end
imac
so this crazy ak footage is still being
limited
by the best 5700 xt graphics option
alright guys so with all of those tests
out of the way we can
safely say that the 10 core cpu is
simply
not worth the extra 400 even for the
tasks that are purely processor based
like xcode logic pro 10 photoshop
and lightroom classic which actually got
slower
with the 10 core cpu assuming both
machines have 64 gigs of ram
now i'm not trying to say that the 10
core is bad it's just that this year's 8
core i7
is insane it's incredibly powerful and
it's not being limited
like the 10 core is now as far as all of
the video editing tests
the high-end imac was only faster
because of the better graphics card
and we know this for sure because the 8
cpu
was not being maxed out in any of the
tests even
raw editing which used to max out the
processor
and since the a-core was running at
higher clock speeds
it could actually be even better for
video editing
like we saw in the canon eos r5 footage
test
so with all of that said in the
beginning of this video
i did mention that the 10 core is
actually worth it for a small number of
people
so let me explain if you're the type of
person who has too much money to even
care about getting the best bang for
your buck
and you want to squeeze out that extra 6
tracks in logic pro 10
12 seconds of build time in xcode or 4
seconds for building one-to-one previews
in lightroom classic
then sure get the 10 core but in my
opinion
100 of people should instead spend that
400
on either upgrading the graphics or
something else like the storage
and with that hopefully this video helps
you out and if it did definitely check
out our apple product merch down below
like our mask
and definitely click the circle above
for our upcoming 5k
imac versus 2019 mac pro comparison
video
and for all of you canon eos r5 users
check out max's video right over there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next one